[Music]
Isaac you got to come with me today
buddy going need your emotional
[Music]
support
Isaac
[Music]
hello anybody
here
hello
[Music]
hello turn right catch your coat look
for falling Stones careful what you E
humble Tong don't wrong stand straight
lose some weight devils in the Smoke Pok
scrape God mistakes drive me to
show me something I don't like tie my
hands and take my eyes I'm not walking
and I won't
see bur my number lose my name I ain't
want to follow Fame spend your precious
time with
TV you can't tell me
[Music]
who wear skirts keep compos don't chase
after boys drench your skin with think
there your future go drive slow don't
say no stop at all the signs put your
brain in school waiting all the lines
show me something I don't like time my
head and take my eyes I'm not walking
and I won't
see burn my number lose my name I ain't
want to follow Fame SP your pre with
TV you can't tell me who
[Music]
oo
show me something I don't like my hand
to take my ey I'm not walking in a
w my lose my name I want to follow F
spend your pre time with
t me something I don't like I want hand
to take I'm not walking in I
see when I'm lose my I don't want to
follow F your
TV you tell me
be I'm not just the other white
[Music]
meat